sois patiente avec moi c'est une
nouvelle chanson
[Musique]
ce qui a tué curtis cooper et sa fiancée
elle a par am et auxi amphétamines
aviez-vous des suspicions qu'il se
droguait à nouveau dessinant
je sais qu artiste avait décroché je
vais pas parler depuis des mois
vous ne croyez pas qu'il puisse y avoir
une minuscule possibilité que quelqu'un
les est piégé pour faire croire à une
overdose
je veux juste réussir à
ce sera ma dernière pièce à dieu tout en
laine vous connaissez cet homme et ce
type est l'un des plus grands
importateurs de pma de la ville est ce
que je peux vivre du nom se regarde
c
je suis venu voir si tu poule on
l'appelle le jardinier il a égorgé un
mec avec des outils de jardinage
c'est les trois gars qui chargent de la
paix est mal dans la file
vous savez curtis va devenir une énorme
star
c'est trois salles au doivent payer
je sais ce que tu as fait
des tous ça va vous tuer
la chercheuse
ça ne ramènera pas pour autant justice
sera rendue
il y à de nouveaux éléments qui selon
nous pourraient être liée à la mort de
votre fils c'est tellement bizarre
j'ai eu cette impression que rona est
vraiment dans le coup
oh
ce mec m'a fait trop flipper
vous vous êtes trompé de personne
tu connaissais très bien me vient
je veux vraiment pas qu'ils aient
d'animosité entre
je pense qu'on doit être plus discrète
cette voie je vais vous tirer dessus
[Musique]
justice sera rendue